the jurogan experience but for young
people in particular is his point
it's having really bad effects i mean he
looks at like he charts the the
introduction of social media and the
rise of like self-harm hospitalizations
for self-harm especially among
adolescent girls yeah it's like been
doubling every three years basically
since facebook was introduced well it's
really fun
the introduction of the smartphone it's
really really 2007. it's uh the coddling
of the american minds people haven't
read it it's really good and talking to
jonathan and getting the the sort of he
it's almost like he's
he's sending out a warning like the
british are coming the british it really
is like it the the dangers are only
going to be exacerbated by ar
and whatever new technology comes along
and haptic feedback suits and all this
chaos the all the new stuff that's going
to be invented over the next 10 years 20
years is only going to be more immersive
yeah absolutely i mean he just thinks
that the the social media companies have
to be forced to at least
not
make not let kids on well not like i
mean like at the very least it should be
like cigarettes and booze where they
make a genuine attempt to keep people
under the age of 16 or 18. it's
interesting because there are some
things that for those kids are this is
what's really fascinating the way china
is handling it is so different than
america china's version of tick tock
celebrates academic achievements
athletic achievements it's all science
projects all these different fascinating
things and they lock it out at 10 pm at
10 p.m no one's on it those kids are not
allowed to get on it because they're
trying to
encourage achievement right they're
trying to encourage like like china has
a program to try to make men more manly
like this open program where they're
trying to make men more masculine
they're doing all these things with like
this idea of engineering a society of
more accomplished more successful people
whereas what are we doing on tick tock
kids are [ __ ] dancing and they're
kardashian
they're screaming about veganism and how
blue their hair is and it's it's wild
yeah i wonder the difference is
interesting because i don't think we
should engineer the way our society
interacts with each other but if you
look at the way china's doing it like
they're doing it clearly with this idea
that they want to stimulate young minds
and they want to promote this idea that
doing things that you are you know like
you're going to become more accomplished
you're going to become more athletic
you're going to like these are what
they're trying to encourage i
a
mean
bit reticent about hauling anything up
that the chinese communist party does as
being a great idea
and if we're worried about things like
the new york post article about joe
biden's son's laptop being suppressed by
twitter just wait a year and all of the
people who are being suppressed on on
conventional social media outlets like
just way to get a load of what uh a
bureaucracy would do if they had control
over what the algorithm shows
no denying that no no one would ever uh
argue that
with a [ __ ] clear conscience yeah so
i mean what do you do like i mean the
other thing that height says is maybe
you try to force them to make the
algorithms like not constantly addictive
because i mean i think what people don't
necessarily always think about when
you're using these platforms is that
they're not blank open spaces into which
your friends and the people you're
following are commenting and then it's
just kind of you know filtering down in
a neutral way it's obviously being
rejigged at the back end to maximize the
time that you're spending on the site
all i want all the algorithm wants to do
is to keep you there for one second
longer so they can maximize the time
that you're spending on the on on the
platform
john heights like could you change that
algorithm so that it's like you know
more fulfilling stuff instead of more
addictive stuff and i'm like i don't
know how you would legislate that i
don't know how you would make them do
that that's what china's doing i think
essentially the only way to do it is to
have no algorithms just allow people to
search what they enjoy and find it on
their own the suggested side of youtube
that's what gets you yes and it seems
like they've stopped playing auto
playing new shows
is that real jimmy like
when i watch youtube it doesn't
necessarily always do that anymore
like sometimes it just shows me a new a
new video but sometimes it doesn't
sometimes the video just stops it could
just be
like maybe just change the default
setting to off and maybe if it's turned
back on or something it could be
something like that well that's probably
good but if there was no algorithm
whatsoever you know the argument would
be that well there's probably a lot of
things that you would be introduced to
that you would enjoy that you're going
to miss if there's no algorithm at all
yeah sure and that would be fine i mean
isn't that the way that i wander through
life normally like there's all kinds of
stuff that's out there that i guess
because it's not being constantly shoved
into my face like i don't necessarily
need the most addictive food at all
times i can also just sometimes have a
salad right but the business model for
them like they're concerned with the
most engagement and the best way to get
the most engaged is find out what josh
zepps likes and then show it to him over
and over and over again yeah you know i
mean as you say once ar and like
whenever you talk about like haptic
feedback suits and stuff like that my
mind just goes to like once porn gets
mastered in that world there's gonna be
a large percentage of the population
that's just in the basement for long
periods of time